prpression.
- - Merci.
J Je joins le docteur
SySylvain Dion, vice-président
dede la Fédération des médecins
omomnipraticiens du Québec.
B Bonjour, Dr Dion.
- - Bonjour.
- - On ne savait pas ce que ça
alallait contenir aujourd'hui.
OnOn voit qu'il n'y a pas de
memenace de pénalités.
OnOn change l'approche comme
didisait ma collègue Valérie.
OnOn veut forcer les docteurs à
rerevoir ensemble la gestion...
- - sur les aspects directifs de
fofond on se rejoint.
CeCela nous semblait être une
sosolution inappropriée.
IlIl y a quand même risque de...
cececi dit, comme le disait le
miministre dans les extraits que
vovous avez passés.
L'L'invitation à la main tendue,
cacanevas de travail, nous é éts
dédéjà dedans.
OnOn attendait un retour du
gogouvernement depuis le 21
ococtobre dernier.
OnOn est toujours en attente.
CeCe qu'on a eu finalement c'est
unun projet de loi ce matin.
CeCeci dit, je crois que la
féfédération sans aucun doute va
rereprendre la discussion et
dedemeure disponible pour qu'on
pupuisse augmenter l'accès pour
pepermettre aux Québécois de
d'd'avoir accès à un médecin, ms
auaussi à un autre spécialiste
popourrait répondre à ces besoi.
- - Vous dîtes d'abord qu'il y
auaurait peut-être un risque de.
CeCe que je crois comprendre
auaujourd'hui de M. Dubé, c'est
ququ'il a accès à de l'informatn
popour savoir combien de patiens
àà chaque médecin.
MaMais il n'a pas les noms des
mémédecins.
IlIl faut savoir qui fait quoi.
Y Y aller avec une nouvelle pla-
foforme, ça permet de voir combn
dede rendez-vous se donne et sot
didistribués par clinique
mémédicale.
IlIl fallait je crois une loi pr
pepermettre cela de fonctionner?
- - Premièrement va compléter ue
ananalyse plus fine du projet de
loloi.
OnOn a des gens qui travaillent
susur cela en maintenant.
CoConcernant pour avoir des
nonombres, il y a en ce moment
dadans la loi sur la régie
d'd'assurance-maladie des
dédélimitations de ce qui peut
êêtre diffusé, et dans mon livre
àà moins, je ne suis pas certain
quque c'est donné pour ont été
enenvoyé dans les établissement.
CeCeci dit, ce qu'il y a dans ce
prprojet de loi, c'est peut-être
plplus une mesure...
QuQui elle va nous permet d'avor
unune meilleure appréciation de
l'l'offre et de la demande des
seservices médicaux sur le
teterrain, pour être capable
rérégion par région, d'avoir une
memeilleure idée du déséquilibre
dadans lequel on est.
IlIl y a quelque chose
d'd'intéressant pour qu'on puise
avavoir des données, qu'on puise
écéchanger avec le gouvernement,
etet on est loin de...
- - Le ministre a mis beaucoup
l'l'accent sur : inscrivez-vous.
OnOn pense qu'il y en a 200 000,
mamais c'est peut-être 1 000 000
1/1/2 de patients qui sont
ororphelins.
SiSi cette nouvelle plate-forme
popour prendre des nouveaux
rerendez-vous.
OnOn ne passera plus par des
plplate-forme...
LeLes gens, ce qu'ils veulent
susurtout savoir, est-ce que la,
çaça va marcher?
EsEst-ce qu'ils vont pouvoir
prprendre un rendez-vous et le
tetenir dans un certain nombre e
jojours et ne pas avoir à attene
trtrois ans, quatre ans, et ne s
sese ramasser avec des cassettes
épépouvantables pour pouvoir
rerenouveler des prescriptions.
- - Ce qu'on a proposé au
gogouvernement, c'est de demandr
l'l'accès à un médecin de famil,
etet de savoir où aller...
EtEt le ministre a un peu évoqué
dadans les différents points de
prpresse, c'est de dire à des
groupes de patients, ça rejoint
l'l'approche qu'on avait.
OuOui peut-être d'un médecin de
fafamille, mais ça pourrait un
auautre professionnel, un et une
ininfirmière, un pharmacien, et.
C'C'est de faire un accès dirig,
popour que les patients arrêtent
dede multiples appels pour pouvr
êêtre vu dans un délai,
lolorsqu'ils ont des besoins.
DDès 880 000 patients qui sont
acactuellement inscrivent,
bebeaucoup de ces patients, ce
n'n'est pas nécessairement d'avr
acaccès à leur médecin famille,à
mamais à un médecin de famille.
IlIls n'ont pas tous des besoins
dede vue demain, c'est patients
onont besoin d'être vus.
- - Pour les sanctions, ce qu'on
cocomprend, c'est que c'est pour
plplus tard.
CeCe n'est pas par méthode, c'et
papar médecin.
LeLe gouvernement travaille
mamanifestement à avoir accès à
dedes données, avoir un portrait
cocomplet.
S'S'il voit quelque chose qui le
dédéplaît, JMS qui ne reçoit pas
susuffisamment de patients, les
sasanctions vont finir par veni.
EsEst-ce que vous comprenez la
mmême chose que moi?
- - Effectivement, le projet de
loloi, quand on le lit, on f fat
réréférence à des dispositions
réréglementaires qui pourront êe
adadoptées...
OnOn a des craintes, qu'à un
momoment donné, le gouvernement
popourrait...
SaSans laisser le temps au terrn
dede s'adapter.
OnOn sort un peu de l'inscriptin
inindividuelle d'un patient à un
mémédecin, Mesdames davantage à
unune approche de groupe.
IlIls doivent falloir avoir du
tetemps pour pouvoir faire bougr
leles indicateurs.
CoComme je le disais, oui, c'est
leles groupes de pratiques, mais
ilil y a aussi peut-être des
spspécialistes en dehors.
QuQu'en une blessure ce qui est
spsportive.
L'L'accès aux pharmacien est déà
ququelque chose qui existe, mais
popourrait développer.
DiDiscuter des effets secondairs
avavec son médecin, ça pourrait
êêtre fait avec un pharmacien.
- - Merci beaucoup docteurs ayan